any movie with his troubled at
production as the new masters of the
universe is bound to foster a whole
mythology of rumors and speculation and
by the power of Grayskull his or the
latest on the future adventures of
eternia's greatest warrior in early 2019
the finals later production staff for
Masters of the Universe finally began to
gel David Goya hood earlier delivered a
script treatment for the new movie and
was briefly in talks to direct opted to
serve as executive producer on the
project instead due to other directorial
commitments in his place to studio hired
the directorial sibling duo Adam and
Aaron a best known for the comedy band
of robbers a modernized pseudo sequel
take on The Adventures of Huckleberry
Finn with his main characters portrayed
as adults
finally screenwriters ask Markham and
Matt Holloway best known for their
credits on the original Iron Man have
taken a fresh pass of the script with
koi and at least four other known
writers having made their attempt at
cracking the story it's not yet clear
how much credit any of them will receive
or if any of their previous ideas will
make it into the final product Koya
script in particular appeared to have
been relatively close to completion but
Markham and Holloway still reportedly
started over from scratch you are all
aware of the penalty
you can't have a Masters of the Universe
movie without a star to play he-man and
in 2019 the new version found us lead in
Noah Santonio arguably best known for
his work in the Netflix rom-com - all
the boys I've loved before centenares
casting marks more than a slight
departure from his predecessor in the
role Dolph Lundgren
this appears to be an intentional move
when asked about his preparation for the
project Santonio teased it's a new
universe the knee brothers Adam and
Aaron knee there directing yet another
filmmakers in charge of the story and
they are doing one hell of a job
developing the world and all these
things a new perspective on the
characters and their setting is to be
expected from any reboot of a bond and
property but as is always the case fans
are quick to offer their opinions on
centenares casting critical Twitter
users called the young actor everything
from a fine actor but a poor choice for
he-man the downright pathetic
of course Antonia was far from the first
star to suffer the sting of pre-emptive
scorn even Heath Ledger's initial
casting as a Joker was met with outright
uproar from comic fans I thought my
jokes were bad Dolph Lundgren played the
original live-action he-man in the 1987
Masters of the Universe film and in an
era of pop culture callbacks and novelty
cameos there's no doubt that many
longtime fans would appreciate an
appearance in the reboot at one point a
lone grin was indeed active the sauce
after for the movie with previous
director John choo having publicly
expressed an interest in including him
in some way this interest however
doesn't appear to have ever brought any
serious negotiations to walls casting
Lundgren and the choose direction and
chewed apart of the project in 2014
Lungren himself has in the past
expressed his own interest in being
involved in 2012 he called the reboots a
good idea but I wouldn't want to take my
shirt off again for three months
Lundgren then suggested that he could
play Hemans father King Randor instead
of course that was some time ago but
Lundgren is still very much around and
enjoying a healthy bump in his celebrity
status having recently appeared in
Aquaman and having reprised his famous
role as Ivan Drago in Creed 2 getting
him involved with the Masters of the
Universe will be a fun way to hug back
to the franchise's history and older
he-man fans are bound to love
[Music]
when a films such as masters of the
universe struggles to find its feet
movie studios tend to keep production
updates very low-key because of the
inevitable fragility of the
pre-production process as such not much
is known about how this new film will
actually look but a few choice teasers
have reached fans nonetheless the only
tantalizing Peaks we've yet seen of the
new movies visual conception came from
yet another of the movies former
directors jeff wadlow what lo who was on
the project from 2014 to 2017
commissioned prosthetics designer and
sculptor mario torres to mark up some
busts of two secondary characters from
Eternia beastman and ram man torres
later shared images of these sculptures
on his Instagram accounts revealing the
signs that seemed to indicate the more
realistic and gritty film than the 1987
original at 2019 s and your Masters of
the Universe fan convention powercon
director Kevin Smith was announced as a
last-minute guest of honor
just days before the calm began this
appearance ended up being a surprise
reveal for a brand new animated Masters
of the Universe limited series for
Netflix entitled masters of the universe
revelation with Smith on board as
executive producer very little has been
revealed about the projects so far but
what is known is that the story is set
to resolve and finish business from the
original animated series two seasons
which ran from 1983 to 1985 currently
there is no announced release date but
the series will be produced by the
powerhouse animation studio which was
also behind Netflix's Castlevania
animated series for the moment there's
no official word and no reason to
believe that this modern return to the
animated source material has anything to
do with sony's live-action feature film
it is clear however that humans future
is finally heating up after a very long
and very cold break for longtime fans of
the franchise check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite
franchises are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and at the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]